why hello it's quite warm in here what
are you finding this up with Anna oh
well these are just dunno some top
female scientists in a card game so this
is something which we have created for
our radio show that it's science our and
expect my phone if you don't listen to
that we are 7 p.m. every tuesday during
term time and there's a link to a penis
in the description and we are doing a
female scientist special this tuesday
the 17th and what we've done for that is
create this deck of cards as you can see
here they are like a certain well-known
card game where you have scores for
characteristics and are characteristics
of these scientists you've got
innovation impact obscurity and
badassery and you can play a game with
them and on each card you've got a
biography of what each scientist did
there's also they're separated by the
field so for example we can show cards
come with yeah we've got a gray surface
whose please mathematician got Dorothy
Hill who's a geologist we've got jane
goodal chimp lady it was a bottle baby
yes we've got to find a physicist for my
channel Lisa Meitner who's a physicist
Lisa Meitner who was praised as being
the German chimeric Urey Nobel Prize I
don't have any chemists in my day honey
I got all the case Andrey may not daily
we've learned so much about doing the
step there's so many amazing women in
here that I just I didn't know of before
yes not neither of us knew about more
than about I'd say four or five women
and we'd love it if you guys could join
lungs what we've done is when we go live
on Tuesday we're going to be paying all
these cars in an imgur album and you can
then print them out yourself and you can
play you can also use them as a
classroom till we'd love it if people
will print these out an use them in
schools were might be able to get these
printed physically yeah hopefully when
are you gonna get these so more
information about that should be coming
in the future but for now I think we're
just gonna play a quick game and show
you show off some of the women in this
deck yeah and I think I'm gonna win oh
no definitely not Oh women always win
well in this game they always to do you
think who determines you guys first you
wanna play rock paper scissors I want
III dem go
yes okay I'll go first badassery 89 is
up marry me not David first black woman
to receive a PhD she was pretty bad yeah
right badassery 10 guess who I've got
your a Grace Hopper yes Commodore hey
you can't beat a battle cruiser send
your destroyer oh well obscurity 804
Mariani innovation 9 who's that Linda be
buck sense of smell liver price yep very
important we've discovered you know how
our sense of smell works it's pretty but
I was only really recent wasn't it was
like the late 90s yeah obscurity 64 this
is not going away that's your favorite
card as well yeah yeah jocelyn bell for
now is one day you know I think really
needs to be up there on the list
innovation 87 yellow nothing right come
on come at me bro obscurity nine also
900 there you go in the middle I got
Florence basket I've got Maria Cooper
Maya so that's a pretty part that is a
top from not that it's a top female
scientist impact 59 no really nutter
hypatia Hypatia she's yeah not she's
been dead for long enough that we can
say that she's not the straightest yeah
you've got a lot to turn around here
innovation 95 Marie Curie sorry
Sklodowska can't really currently do it
obscurity 10 gerty cori the fact that
when we were ranking these cards neither
of us knew watching ton no I saw quite a
while to work it out even the biography
on the Nobel Prize yeah we have arrived
at a very much they even the Nobel
Committee don't know what you innovation
80 wow you were just turning this around
I'm not happy with this it may break my
son I'll stop us two teaser spoiler car
uh impact nine impact 90 I've got Grace
Hopper now oh I mean answer again from
you but I voted mathematicians yeah
badassery 570 the hydration welcome okay
well as it turns out this game was
really hard to win that was a bit of
stalemate but he wasn't it yeah but if
you want to see who's actually going to
win join us on tuesday on expression FM
for the science our special ah daddy